hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
today I want to talk about one thing I
teased a little bit at the end of the
previous video which of course if you
haven't seen the previous video that
talks about all 100 tears in the battle
past if you haven't seen it yet so
there's a lot of cool interesting stuff
in there and there's actually a huge
increase in steel and Salvage compared
from last season to this season so
definitely go check that video out when
you get the chance especially after this
one but I tease that there was two new
emotes that are currently in the game at
the moment and then two new executions
that are actually in a trailer that they
haven't mentioned yet so we're gonna be
going over those four things or
technically 6 but I'll get into it in
the video but either way I'd like to be
if you do enjoy subscribe for new I
cover the informational site a foreigner
that being the balance changes to hear
updates the patch notes of the leaks if
ever we kept it today with everything
happening in the world of foreigner I
never miss out one update definitely
stay subscribe the channel
and with that let's get started with
today's video see yet today is gonna be
a bit of a shorter video but like I said
the first ones are the emotes and
currently they're in the game right now
they're available for all heroes I
believe they are both free mo roam
emotes or if they're not I think one is
free roam one is combat I didn't bother
checking but they are called the dubious
assessment and then one of the shrugs
which are seeing on screen now both of
those emotes are available currently
right now as I'm making this video they
released with the year for season 2 you
know release patch so those were already
there they didn't explain these in the
dev stream so I was a little bit
confused when I saw these but yeah they
are currently in the game right now if
you want to grab those other than that
we have the teases for only two but I'm
convinced there's two more that they
haven't shown yet as right here in the
beginning of the trailer you can see
warden beating up a guy with the loot
that is most definitely an execution and
something we haven't seen in the game
yet this is most likely in line with the
music emotes we got in the honor games
and since metal trials isn't exactly the
Honor Games but it's kind of like it
with the crowd and the camaraderie and
the celebration of the honor games those
emotes would obviously want to be remade
with a little bit extra flavor but
that's not the only thing they teased as
we see here we see T on D beating up a
conch with the horn I believe there is
probably ones for the
other two instruments as well but of
course they don't want to show
everything to us right away
so I have this weird hypothesis that
maybe in every single season in year
four we're gonna get one event regarding
the honor game celebration with stuff
relating to music in like the form of
emotes and executions although it
probably would get pretty stale after a
while so I think in season 3 they'd be
adding new instruments and in season for
making executions out of those new
instruments but that's just what I think
either way these are definitely - two
emotes that are already in the game now
and two new executions possibly four new
executions that are coming to the game
at some point in time with the new items
and the new instruments I'm super
excited like I said we only know about -
maybe there's four maybe they only made
two maybe they're showing us everything
now I hope not cuz I'd really like to
see somebody get the [ __ ] beat out of
them with a flute but that's just me
yeah let me know what you guys think
about these musical beat em up
instrument executions super excited to
grab those definitely to grab the horn
one as it's definitely some super big BM
but either way like to be if you do
enjoy go subscribe if we knew I covered
the informational side of forum that
being the balance changes - here it fits
the Patchett's of the leaks if everybody
kept it today with everything happened
in the world of foreigner I never miss
that one enough Manito if we stay
subscribe the channel with that
take care guys peace out and enjoy the
new season
[Music]
you